davis luca meine lieben freunde ich
mache aber heute wieder crysis die ihr
für mich gemacht habt auf caputh
von daher sonnenbrille auf wir starten
mit dem quiz für unterentwickelte von
logi unterstrich der unterstrich lauch
robin nancy und china sind dabei diese
idioten immer herkommen aber gott ich
bin gespannt ob diesmal ein paar
ernstzunehmendere fragen mit dabei sind
als noch beim letzten video los geht's
wie lang ist die größte nase der welt
wenn da
[Musik]
die frage ist halt von wo man die nase
misst das macht man jetzt so einfach ich
klicke jetzt einfach mal auf zehn
zentimeter
gleiches die zweite frage allerdings ein
bisschen sinnvoller wie viel geld gibt
eine frau pro jahr in deutschland für
schminke aus
ich weiß dass sandra auf jeden fall sehr
sehr viel geld für schminke ausgibt aber
es geht ja hier um den
durchschnittsdeutschen von daher würde
ich sagen 80 bis 100
werde ich irgendeine frage noch richtig
haben frage nummer drei wie viel gramm
code produziert ein mensch im
durchschnitt pro tag ihr seid doch also
ich gehe pro tag zwei mal kacken und
daher würde ich sagen roundabout ein
kilo
[Musik]
100 bis 200 gramm das ist wie groß ist
das größte insekten der welt ja was
wollen wir jetzt ein foto nehmen ich
hasse insekten
oh mein gott ich hasse insekten das
größte insekt der welt ich würde sagen
komm ich vielleicht einen rein da ist
mir scheißegal
fünfte frage wie viele bilder werden pro
sekunde auf instagram veröffentlicht
ich würde sagen pro sekunde könnten
schon 1000 bilder seien
jetzt alle früchte die glatze ist eine
ausgefallene frisur
ist es wahr
es ist ja eine ausgefallene frisur weil
die haare ausgefallen sind die lang ist
die größte schlange der welt dass du oh
mein gott ich habe nichts gegen
schlangen aber so ein fettes cobra
anaconda dem bericht die längste
schlange ich würde sagen neue mieter die
schon recht diese
frage wie viele stunden videomaterial
werden roth hat auf youtube hochgeladen
warum das bild es gibt gar keinen sinn
100000 kommen geblieben
mit welcher geschwindigkeit hink eltmann
ich würde sagen wo am milliliter pro
sekunde ich konnte ja auch nie so
richtig so sachen umrechnen so von
milliliter pro sekunde dann im kilometer
pro stunde oder irgendwie so ich würde
sagen es sind schon ist so ein
mittelding so 68 bis 80 minuten
letzte frage wie viel urin scheidet eine
erwachsener innerhalb von 24 stunden aus
ich in der toilette perfekt ich würde
sagen
815 das ist zukunft
ich will mir das ranking gar nicht
angucken ich werde ihr letzter platz
sein
er hätte nicht zweiter
bin ich erst das kann doch nicht sein oh
mein gott
[Musik]
ach so ich passe das nächste quiz das
wir spielen werden ist das ultimative
laser luca quiz 2 von con unterstrichen
logi
ich hoffe ernste fragen frage noch mal
eins wie viele blogs hat luca schon
ungefähr auf seinem kanal hochladen da
kommt es helfen bild von mir früher mit
einem blog an guck mal wie viele blogs
habe ich schon ungefähr hochgeladen
hätten die an eine ganze die ganze
blocks zählen müssen ich würde sagen
nicht so viel ich glaube
184 es müsste
er 30 mehr oder weniger ich also in
meinen gedanken gibt ich mir ein punkt
welchen iq hat luca wir haben eine
mehrfachauswahl
-100 so tief im meeresgrund laut hat
kein ego ist genauso tief wie sein
niveau ich würde mal sagen alles ist
richtig
[Musik]
das ist wirklich
welches lebe wie gesagt die längste nase
ja klar ich logisch blue kann
dabei wollte er nicht verarschen wahr
oder falsch lukat seine eigene
bettwäsche rausgebracht
ich hab mal tatsächlich eigene
bettwäsche rausgebracht ja
es ist aber schon sehr lange her
walter dass sich daran auch leute
erinnern können ich habe auch so lange
nichts mehr ausgemacht im lukas aigner
aber wenn ihr was kaufen wollt kann ich
euch den
schon wieder wahr oder falsch luca ist
mit bibi verwandte dort können wir ganz
schnell abhaken das ist falsch oh mein
gott das foto sieht so täuschend echt
aus wo ist das her sechste frage
vervollständigen den satz ok keine frage
als kleinkind wurde luca öfter damit er
mit dem weinen aufhörte angefühlt
[Musik]
wie kann man sich sowas mehr in riehl
talk ihr wisst manchmal mehr als ich ne
welches bild gehört zum folgenden satz
okay der satz lautet naja
[Musik]
was ist das und
was ist das wie vielen sternen wurde der
podcast dick und doof auf spotify
bewertet wird alles über 5 kann nicht
sein von daher glaube ich 4,7
dass wir überhaupt was über 1 haben bei
den sternen ist eigentlich ihre
vorletzte frage welcher titel hat das
kürzeste youtube video auf dem kanal
laser luca
roccoli block 2 was gerade los ist ich
darf nicht beruflich glaubt frohe
weihnachten
es ist ja über krass bearbeitet hier
alles setzte frage hier im quiz von
jesse wie hießen die kaninchen von sarah
und luca krümmel und klopfe ich
muss hier den ersten platz belegt alles
andere weckt dritter platz sie die dumme
sie beiseite
schmiss für laser flop von wird punkte
vielleicht habe ich ein bisschen ernst
nehmen fragen numero uno wie schmecken
kinder
[Musik]
natürlich im kochtopf es liegt an der
soße vielleicht ja nach käse perfekt da
jeder weiß dass kinder der käse
schmecken frage nummer 2 warum ist die
banane kommen weil sie zur sonne hin
wächst nach wundervoll
machen ganz fix weiter dritte frage ich
sag's euch jetzt wird rasiert wie viele
blätter klopapier verbraucht ein mensch
im jahr ich würde erstmal auf den tag
warum nicht klopapierrolle
und warum ist seine musik als wenn die
bei herr der ringe gerade im dorf
einnehmen
[Musik]
20.000
aber das ist gleich auch noch darauf
bezogen dass wenn man das mal
benutzernamen pickel auszudrücken oder
eiweiß wegzuwischen oder so frage nummer
vier von neun apropos klopapier wie
viele lagen bevorzugen die meisten
deutschen ich glaube wirklich
[Musik]
43 ist auch richtig
krieg jetzt nur die halbe punktzahl oder
wie es hat jetzt wie viel wiegt
durchschnittlich großer kurze aber was
hat mir alles sie mit mit kappe und ich
auf dem dixi klo durchschnittlich großer
code ich würde sagen
100 bis 150 gramm
[Musik]
scheiße kennt sich scheiße also sechste
frage und wie viel prozent von
menschlichen kot sind proteine
was ist denn das für ein bild
ich würde sagen unter 5 der körper
proteine ich eigentlich benötigt und
dann nicht ausschaltet
das ist dumm
unter 5 sind doch auch zwei bis 25
prozent sei dank ich gehe ich mal wieder
ein punkt viel zu großer tisch zu machen
wahr oder falsch nachts ist es kälter
als draußen das ist falsch
[Musik]
es gibt doch gar keinen sinn dass das
wahr ist und warum bin ich auf dem mond
wehr nahm von jeder tierart jeweils
beide geschlechter mit auf die arche ich
bin dass ich als jesus
keine ahnung noah sow die arche noah da
guck mal einer an
[Musik]
letzte frage ich glaube ich war doch
hier einschalten welche dieser spinnen
[Musik]
bis für laser flop siegerpodest wäre es
auf den dritten platz nancy mein gott
bin ich zweiter
wenn erst hat sich gereicht wird erst
wenn's robin ist macht video ende